[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis schönen guten abend wir
haben jetzt die wichtigsten nachrichten
für sie zusammengefasst in zehn minuten
die themen
wald ist schluss mit dem neuen euro
ticket folgen nach dem boom höhere
preise als vorher
nah dran an der politik tausende
neugierige beim tag der offenen tür
kanzler und minister stellen sich den
fragen der bürger
und zwischen ausnahmezustand und der
sehnsucht nach normalität die menschen
in odessa nach fast einem halben jahr
krieg
das neue euro ticket ist äußerst beliebt
aber bald läuft es aus damit können seit
juni und noch bis ende august reisende
mit dem nah und regionalverkehr durch
ganz deutschland fahren etwa 30
millionen menschen haben das nach
schätzung der verkehrsbetriebe jeden
monat kräftig genutzt vor allem auf
ländlichen strecken in tourismusgebieten
waren zum teil doppelt so viele
unterwegs wie sonst immer lauter werden
deshalb die forderung dass mein euro
ticket zu verlängern an der stadt fällt
verreisen so günstig wie lange nicht zum
beispiel nach berlin für viele ist das
billig ticket ein echter gewinn
besonders jetzt in der ferienzeit
neuartige fange ich super wir haben das
ganze familie benutzt und sind quer
durch deutschland das ist eine sehr gute
geschichte aber wir sollten natürlich
gucken dass wir auch alternativen dann
für die zukunft haben und die
bundesregierung sollte den öffentlichen
nahverkehr fördern die idee ist gut und
ist auch wichtig ja weil wir auch anders
nicht mehr lange so existieren können
die bisher das dass jeder ein auto hatte
und so weiter das ist völlig absurd doch
die preiswerte sommerticket aktion läuft
den wenigen tagen aus die kosten im
nahverkehr könnten ab september stark
steigen befürchten verbraucherschützer
die gefahr steht im raum dass nach einem
sommer in dem man mit dem
kostengünstigen einfachen 9 euro ticket
den öffentlichen nahverkehr nutzen
konnte ein rückschlag im herbst kommt
und drastischen preiserhöhungen aufgrund
gestiegener energiepreise die
verbraucherzentralen fordern deshalb ein
29 euro monatsticket nutzbar in ganz
deutschland andere bringen ein
jahresticket für 365 euro ins gespräch
bundesfinanzminister lindner lehnt die
verlängerung des billig tickets
allerdings ab es fehle dafür schlicht
das geld die sanierung der wichtigsten
bahnstrecken sei teuer und zwingend
notwendig das sagt auch verkehrsminister
wissing zur möglichen nachfolge eines
sondertickets weiter aus und verweist
auf die bundesländer es ist letztlich
die zuständigkeit der länder den öpnv
voranzubringen aber wenn wir das
gemeinsam machen und der bund auch tempo
macht bei der digitalisierung und
modernisierung der strukturen dann wird
es für die fahrgäste besser einfacher
und eben benutzerfreundlicher klar ist
ab 1 september ist das 9 euro ticket
geschichte und ein nachfolger ist noch
nicht in sicht
es war eine der besten ideen die wir
hatten sagte der kanzler heute zum neuen
euro ticket und zwar beim tag der
offenen tür der bundesregierung
am wochenende konnten interessierte mal
einen blick hinter die politischen
kulissen werfen während olaf scholz und
die ministerinnen und minister rede und
antwort standen heike slansky hat sich
das angeschaut
schlange stehen um einmal auf
tuchfühlung im zentrum der macht die
politischen akteure zu erleben nach zwei
jahren corona pause öffnet die regierung
wieder ihre pforten erwartungen ich
freue mich
dass man hautnah erlebt wo die mächtigen
hier sowohl auf das möglicherweise eine
persönliche ebene mit dem kasseler heute
möglich ist wenn es keine offizielle
pressemitteilung ist dass man auch mal
ein bisschen lockerer die fragen von ihm
beantwortet bekommt der kanzler zwar
betont locker unmittelbar vor seiner
kanada so steht den interessierten rede
und antwort so wie man ihn kennt die
themen vielfältig ernstes und heiteres
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die meisten bürger und bürger verdienen
ja der andrang beim beliebtesten
minister deutschlands ebenfalls ähnlich
hoch immerhin beim vizekanzler geht erst
einmal etwas lockerer zu
selten machen musste tag der offenen tür
politik trifft auf bürgerfragen und
sorgen vor allem vor dem winter die
hohen gaspreise die
versorgungssicherheit
gelingt ist deutschland 15 bis 20
prozent gas einzusparen dass es viel
dann haben wir eine richtig gute chance
mit den genannten maßnahmen über den
winter zu kommen an einem weiteren
entlastungspaket werde gearbeitet aber
der finanzminister bleibt dabei wir
müssen innerhalb der grenzen der
schulden
genau darüber wird innerhalb der ampel
parteien heftig hinter den kulissen
gestritten ausgang offen
tank rabatt und neun euro ticket laufen
bald aus vieles dürfte demnächst noch
teurer werden vor den folgen der hohen
inflation warnt der deutsche
sparkassenverband
sparen sei für viele kaum noch möglich
bis zu 60 prozent der deutschen
haushalte müssten ihre gesamten
einkünfte monatlich für die reine
lebenshaltung einsetzen
bei der suche nach der ursache für das
fischsterben in der oder verschärft sich
der ton zwischen polen und deutschland
die polnische umweltministerin warf den
deutschen behörden wirklich fake news
also falschmeldungen vor gestern hatte
das brandenburger umweltministerium
mitgeteilt dass sind proben eine hohe
pestizid belastung gefunden wurde die
aber wohl nicht unmittelbar tödlich
gewesen sei bisher ist nach wie vor
unklar was das fischsterben ausgelöst
hat in polen und deutschland wurden rund
200 tonnen verendeter tiere eingesammelt
fast ein halbes jahr dauert der krieg in
der ukraine bereits ein halbes jahr
zwischen ausnahmezustand auf der einen
seite und dem wunsch nach ein bisschen
normalität auf der anderen so geht es
wohl vielen menschen in der ukraine auch
und das strategisch so wichtigen
hafenstadt odessa die immer wieder von
raketen getroffen wird die front ist
etwa 100 kilometer entfernt aus odessa
berichtet herr hebestreit
sie dir an was ihr getan habt schreibt
sie in die handy und 54 ihre schwester
in russland die zerstörte ferienanlage
von stalker östlich von odessa russische
raketen sind eingeschlagen ukraine sonst
urlaub machen nicht zum ersten mal das
feriengebiet lichts an einer strategisch
wichtigen brücke die geschosse sind
offenbar nicht besonders zielgenau
das ist viel arbeit keine ahnung wie wir
das schaffen sollen das dach muss vor
dem winter repariert werden sonst richte
das rein
mitten in odessa so etwas wie alltag
müde nach einer weiteren nacht
unterbrochen von luftalarm besuchen
viele den markt gehen bummeln aber das
geld ist knapp
es gibt hier eigentlich alles zu kaufen
aber die preise sind stark gestiegen ich
verkaufe hier rund 60 prozent weniger
als im letzten sommer wer kann fährt an
den einzigen vom militär freigegebenen
badestrand eine stunde außerhalb der
stadt können sie über das wochenende ein
wenig abschalten aus dem pharma andré
hat diesen beach club mitten im krieg
zusammengezimmert
das leben geht weiter und wir müssen
irgendwas tun wir haben nur dieses eine
leben und das müssen wir jetzt leben und
so sind krieg und luftangriffe für einen
nachmittag ganz weit weg
blicken wir nach russland denn dort gab
es einen anschlag auf das auto des
rechts nationalisten alexander dugin der
als vordenker für die politik von
präsident putin gilt bei der explosion
der autobombe in der nacht kam dessen
tochter da ja dugena ums leben die
allein im auto saß
sie befürwortete ebenso wie ihr vater
den krieg gegen die ukraine
vermutet wird dass alexander dugin das
eigentliche ziel des anschlags war das
außenministerium in moskau macht die
ukraine verantwortlich kiew weist das
zurück
es war ein wochenende voller gewalt in
der somalischen hauptstadt mogadischu
islamisten der al shabab miliz hatten am
freitagabend einen bei politikern
beliebtes hotel gestürmt und geiseln
genommen nach rund 30 stunden gelang es
elite kräften die ata kinder nachts zu
beenden mindestens 21 menschen wurden
getötet und mehr als 110 verletzt die
extremistische al-shabaab-miliz versucht
seit jahren die regierung in somalia zu
stürzen
er war der selbst ernannte könig von
deutschland der 1996 verstorbene musiker
rio reiser mutter erfährt nun post um
eine besondere ehrung in berlin ist ein
platz nach ihm benannt worden der
heinrich platz im bezirk kreuzberg ist
seit heute der rio reiser platz der
ehemalige sänger der band ton steine
scherben hatte selbst lange in kreuzberg
gebucht
und blicken wir noch aufs wetter morgen
scheint bei 23 bis 30 grad oft die sonne
im osten sachsens und im südosten
bayerns kann es auch etwas regnen
hier werden nur 16 bis 25 grad erreicht
und auch die kommenden tage bleiben
meist trocken und es wird etwas wärmer
anne gellinek hat um 21.45 das
heute-journal für sie und jetzt geht es
direkt weiter mit den european
championships viel spaß
[Musik]